south africa's army says that it will
deploy soldiers to help quell unrest
sparked by the jailing of former
president jacob zuma
at least six people have been killed in
the looting and protests
violence broke out last week when zuma
began serving a 15-month sentence for
contempt of court
now looters have ransacked a mall in the
coastal city of durban overnight
another shopping mall lay in ruins in
nearby
regional capital of kwazulu-natal after
it was
torched on sunday this unrest is mainly
concentrated
in zuma's home province of kazulu
natal but it is also spreading to
johannesburg
south africa's economic powerhouse
south africa's president tsio ramaposa
has condemned the violence
here's what he had to say those who
may be hurt and angry at this moment
there can never be any justification
whatsoever for anybody to embark on
violent and destructive
and disruptive actions that negatively
affect the rights of others
and let's get more on this now we are
joined by dw's very own christine mundo
who's standing by in cape town
um christine we we understand that south
africa's army is moving
into the affected regions now what more
can you tell us about this unrest
sarah it is clear that this unrest is
intensifying it started breaking out
last week friday that was uh some hours
after the former president
had been incarcerated it started out as
people saying
free jacob zuma they had mobilized
around key highways in the country
blocking roads um but by the time we
were into the weekend
it was clear that this was going beyond
that we now saw images of people
ransacking factories shops you talked
about the burning of
a shopping mall various trucks were
satellites and truck drivers targeted
and so there has been an intensification
of this violence in many cases
if you look at that footage um you
either do not see
police or where there are police uh they
appear to be helpless
as a mob runs how to scout a going a
mark
uh in a particular location and so as we
understand it
the police have asked uh four assistants
and
the soldiers that are going to be
deployed in the true provinces in
kwazulu and
the homeland uh former president jacob
zuma and in halting home to johannesburg
uh soldiers we're not clear at the
extent
of the deployment how many soldiers how
long it will be but it is clear police
need help
uh because the violence is escalating
sarah
who's behind the violence christine
well this is the thing initially you had
uh people in the former president's camp
i would name one person particularly his
daughter
dude her twitter account is very active
she has been
retweeting some of the videos of the
unrest in the country
essentially mobilizing the former
president supporters
saying things like amandla which means
power to the people this is us
taking a stand against what they call
the unconstitutional
detention of her father so there is that
but it is also clear that there are now
opportunistic criminals
who've jumped onto this um and you
certainly heard the president allude to
it last night as well people
walking into shops and ransacking people
are saying that no longer has anything
to
do with the former president's detention
but these are now just
criminals violent criminals who have now
taken advantage of the situation because
there are criminals out in the street so
there certainly is uh the responsibility
to be born by people
in the former president's camp who seem
to be mobilizing people
in some cases on tribal and ethnic lines
telling people to go out
and and cause chaos until their
president from the prison jacob zuma is
freed
but they have lost control of that
situation now it
appears all sorts of criminal elements
are now taking it because some of the
the looting and the ransacking appears
to have some coordination to it sarah
and can you tell us a little bit more
about you know you've mentioned it there
the fact that
zuma's appeal trial was really a big
trigger um
for for all of this violence christine
what are the his chances of success now
at this new court hearing just tell us
what's going on there
well essentially zuma's lawyers have to
to is to make the case they've got to
demonstrate
one of three things here that the court
that handed him the sentence which is by
the way the court that he is appealing
at now he's asked this court
to make a rescission of its ruling to
basically cancel
its ruling he's got to demonstrate three
things one that the judgment was
fraudulent
two that the court somehow made a
mistake in its ruling
or three that new information new
documents have emerged
since the court made its ruling a lot of
legal experts
out there are listening to the case
we're watching it live as it's happening
uh in this country it is being streamed
a lot of people of the view that he's
not been able to successfully
demonstrate
either of those three conditions so it
is looking like
it's going to be an uphill battle for
this president before the president of
south africa
to have the court that founded that
convicted him uh and sentenced him
to rescind that particular decision he
remains in behind bars
as we speak christine windua with the
view from south africa thank you so much
christine